people watching Kyle Lowry do that for
17 years
[Applause]
Robinson fires and hits a three-pointer
Duncan Robinson three for three all here
to start the fourth quarter and it's a
two-point game in 28 minutes eight of 11
from the field four of five from
downtown
Miami's overcome a 15-point deficit
Duncan Robinson drives and finishes
another tough shot 10 straight points by
the Heat and Denver needs a timeout
[Applause]
10 points from Duncan Robinson in the
fourth but make no mistake about it bam
is making plays as a playmaker
recognizing you're putting your Center
in position to read and react the
quarterback position and he is making
the right reads delivering the
basketball and Duncan Robinson has been
a spark plug in a big time Way Off the
Bench